Now that you've added the URI
information to the WeatherContract, step
two of building our Content Provider,
I've got some explaining to do.
At the beginning of our WeatherContract,
you can see we defined
the CONTENT_AUTHORITY.
Next we added strings for
the BASE paths for our URIs.
Note how these paths
match our two tables.
For each of our tables,
LocationEntry and WeatherEntry,
we created a CONTENT_URI that represents
the base location for each table.
Something else that is convenient to
have in the contract are functions to
help build the Content Provider queries.
Now, for some URI builders and
decoder functions for WeatherEntry.
It's convenient to have these, as it
makes fewer places in your code aware of
the actual URI in coding,
keeping this knowledge in the contract.
Strings such as the location setting
can be impended with the impend path
function.
You'll be implementing the build
weather location function shortly.
In this case adding an additional
path to the URI does not
change the type of the URI.
See, they're both type DIR.
We can also use these functions to add
potentially useful query parameters.
In this case, we use a query
parameter for the start date.
Query parameters are useful when, for
when we have a fixed database query that
we want to have some limited
parametrization for.
In this case it will be a parameter for
our join between the two tables.
More on that later.
URI queries look just like
the queries you see in web URLs, and
give us the ability to add more richness
and complexity to our URI contract.
Finally, we have this function that
builds a two part URI with both weather
and date segments.
Below this we have helper functions that
hide the URI structure from our code.
For retrieving values in the URI and
place all this knowledge in one place.
Looking back at our list of URIs,
you can see that for
each URI I called out whether
the URI returned a list of items.
By labeling it with dir for directory or
a single item by labeling it with item.
Cursors returned from a content provider
have unique types based upon their
content and
the base path used for the query.
Android uses a form similar
to the internet media type or
mime type to describe
the type returned by the URI.
Cursors that can return more
than one item are prefixed
by the CURSOR_DIR_BASE_TYPE string.
While cursors that return only
a single item are prefixed by
the CURSOR_ITEM_BASE_TYPE string.
We define these types here for both
the location and the weather queries.